foreign
[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy
the University of Cincinnati has just
proven yet again that colleges and
universities in the United States today
are not centers of Higher Learning but
radioactive wastelands of hard left
indoctrination
the university has just fired Clifford
Adams a music Professor for touching the
third rail of American public discourse
today Adams dared to offend a Muslim
student
Adams tried to Stave off his fate
issuing the abject apology that
totalitarian regimes require of Those
whom they have targeted for Thought
crime Adams said as I reconsider what I
wrote from an online student's Vantage
Point Adam said I now realize that I did
come across like a religious bigot and
that makes me feel horrible I have
inadvertently hurt feelings and offended
many and for that I am deeply sorry
now what terrible thing did this bigoted
Professor say this was after all a music
class not a political one and Adams was
asking his students to give their
impressions of the song Walk On Water a
Muslim student wrote that in an
atmosphere of Trump's presidency and all
the Haiti has promoted the song reminded
listeners that America was built off the
idea of freedom Adams responded to that
the U.S President's first sworn duty is
to protect America from enemies and the
greatest threat to our freedom is not
the president it is the radical Islam
review this list of Islamic terrorist
attacks and then tell me about your hurt
feelings
that's all he said he invited her to
examine and Ponder some unpopular truths
he later explained I wanted a lively
exchange of views and ideas about
closed-minded bigotry and a discussion
about how it is Incorporated in modern
music through a smart academic
Collegiate argument instead I have given
my students the wrong impression that I
am a religious bigot he lamented in the
wake of the controversy that we would
have enjoyed a lively provocative
scholarly argument
continuing his apology Adams wrote it is
above all important that it is
understood that I do not wish to
disparage anyone's religion my remarks
were intended to amplify our ongoing
discussion on the pervasive abuse and
objectification of women in today's
popular music culture
despite the abjectness of Adam's
self-incrimination and apology the
University of Cincinnati's offices of
academic Personnel equal opportunity and
access and Title IX opened an
investigation of him and University
spokesman Greg Vare hastened to contain
the Damage Done by Adam's Venture off
the politically correct reservation
assuring the public that the University
of Cincinnati was committed to
Excellence
and diversity
except of course diversity of thought
what Clifford Adams wrote to the Muslim
student was entirely accurate but truth
is not a factor on University campuses
anymore what matters is how much what is
being said comports with leftist Dogma
anything that contradicts that Dogma is
excoriated and the person who dared to
say it vilified and removed from contact
with all right-thinking people
this isn't just happening in
universities either it is rapidly
becoming the norm in The Wider society
as well anyone who questions the leftist
dogmas that Islam is a religion of peace
and that Muslims are persecuted and
harassed in Donald Trump's America is
pilloried and destroyed the freedom of
speech is a despised and misunderstood
concept and it has become widely
accepted that hate speech so-called is
not protected by the First Amendment and
the slightest negative word about Islam
constitutes that hate speech
note also the totalitarian pattern atoms
subject to Hillary Clinton's recommended
peer pressure and shaming for those who
issue unpopular opinions he gives an
abject apology but it isn't good enough
he must be made an example of for anyone
else who might dare to dissent
the University of Cincinnati ought to be
ashamed it ought to be also picketed and
inundated with protests until Clifford
Adams is reinstated but it is unlikely
that there are enough lovers of Freedom
there who understand the implications of
what has happened and are willing to
stick their necks out
meanwhile in which Muslim country would
Greg Vare or anyone else at the
University of Cincinnati venture to say
that Muslim women are safer than they
are in the U.S because that is what Adam
said
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]